95 of who we are is those unconscious
programs so then becoming conscious of
your unconscious self or how many times
do we have to forget and go unconscious
till we stop forgetting and start
remembering that means the person who's
blaming and complaining and feeling
sorry for themselves and judging others
for the most part that's a program
they're not conscious that they're doing
that they've just done it so many times
that it's automatic right so if the
person wants to truly make the change
then they have to really become
conscious of those unconscious States
now meditation is one of the tools that
we use because meditation is a great way
to get beyond the analytical mind and
and get into the operating system where
those subconscious programs exist so
your conscious mind five percent of your
total mind and then you have your
subconscious mind which is 95 of how
we've been programmed and what separates
is the conscious mind from the
subconscious mind is the analytical mind
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because of my first
business I struggled to stay afloat I
quit my business partner and the thing
that kept me going was studying the
stories of famous entrepreneurs and
seeing how they struggled and seeing
what they had to overcome and listen to
their wisdom motivation gave me the
Courage the strength the belief to go
one more day and see my business through
and in all honesty I still need the
inspiration wisdom motivation today for
my business too so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
activate the Law of Attraction enjoy
and meditation is a great way to teach
people how to slow their brain waves
down
and just like anything else it's a skill
the more you practice the better you get
at it and if you can slow your brain
waves down into this right creative
state then you can rewrite a program
then you can install a new track you can
rehearse a new way of being right now
person who wants to become wealthy or
get the job of their dreams they still
have to fill out all those applications
and they still have to apply because
that's the process in this
three-dimensional reality now
everything that's in this
three-dimensional reality whether it's
an object or a thing or a body or a
person or a place we're sitting
everything gives us the illusion of
Separation I'm here and you're there and
there's space and time between us
so the way we function in
three-dimensional reality is if I'm
aware that I'm sitting here
and I want to walk to the other side of
the room to the door over there I become
aware that I'm here but I'm separate
from that other point of awareness over
there
and the way I get from here to there is
I have to do something so in this plane
of demonstration I gotta move through
space I gotta move my body through space
and when I move through space it takes
time
so time is a function of moving through
space one point of Consciousness to
another point of Consciousness the
thought of me being here and the
experience of me being there takes time
cause and effect but then there's me
here
I'm sitting here then I have my dream
job right and my brain automatically
creates my job somewhere out in my
future over there I'm separate from it
right so I'm separate from my future
just like I'm separate from something
else and so then the only way that I can
get to that future is I gotta do a lot
of things I'm going to work hard I fill
out applications I got to talk to the
right people I gotta go on interviews
and this is how we function in
three-dimensional reality is that is
that like a masculine perspective no
it's just the way we function in the
world right so so everything we want is
going to take time and energy right
because really we're matter trying to
change matter and if your matter trying
to change matter it's just going to take
time and when it doesn't work and you
get angry and frustrated and patient try
to manipulate outcomes we fight for
outcomes we compete for outcomes because
we're matter trying to change matter now
learn the skills make the right choices
make the right sacrifices and meet the
right people and in time you may get
that job nothing wrong with that that's
how we create in this three-dimensional
world
there's an invisible field of energy
that exists Beyond this relative space
and time
and there's no objects there there's no
people there there's no bodies there's
no things there's no places there isn't
even time right now that's a really big
concept for people to wrap their mind
around because it's nothing material
there nothing physical it's a vacuum
void of anything material
what we've learned in our research is
that if you teach people how to take
their attention off of everything
physical and material
everything known
there comes a moment where the brain
begins to switch and we put our
attention instead of on matter
we put our attention on energy
and the quantum field is an invisible
field of energy a frequency that's
filled fertile
with possibility and information
so now
this invisible field of energy connects
everything physical and material in fact
most people when they study matter they
see matters emitting a field but
according to the quantum it's not matter
that's emitting the field it's actually
the field that's slowing down in
frequency and creating matter
okay now if you can reverse that
and get a person to a point where
they're not their face they're not their
culture they're not their age they're
not their profession they're not their
diet they're not they're not a son or
they're not a mother they're not they're
not they're not aware of their cell
phone they're not aware of their car
they're literally their attention is
completely in the present moment
okay
they walked through this little door
they pass through the eye of the needle
and they entered this realm of the
quantum now if you teach people how to
create from the quantum field instead of
from matter
then if they do that properly
and they understand the science of how
then they no longer have to go anywhere
to get what they want in other words
when a person can create the right type
of energy the right type of frequency
from the field and there's a vibrational
match between their energy
and whatever they want in their life
all of a sudden they start drawing
experiences to them out of nowhere they
get the phone call hey synchronicity yes
synchronicity why because you're
synchronizing your energy
to a possibility in your life now in the
quantum
every thought has a frequency
so when a person has the thought of
their new job
and they can feel the frequency of that
thought it wouldn't be lack it wouldn't
be separation it wouldn't be frustration
the frequency of the thought of a new
job would create the feeling of euphoria
excitement Bliss gratitude
and thoughts tend to be Electric in the
quantum field and feelings tend to be
magnetic
and now we teach people how to create a
Wi-Fi signal when when they connect to
the field
and they literally change their energy
the thought being the electrical charge
the feeling being the magnetic charge
and how you think and how you feel is
broadcasting energy
now
there's a little bit more that has to
happen because you have to have
coherence in your brain the brain's got
to be very orderly and it's emitting a
field and which it can do with stress
stress stress is static stress you
disconnect because all of your attention
is going on everything physical and
material and you're drawing from this
energy that's surrounding your body and
you're turning into chemistry and now
you're isolated you're separate so we
teach people how to get that brain
coherence going on that hard coherence
going and coherence is rhythm and Order
and now you have this wi-fi signal and
when there's a vibrational match or
you've synchronized your energy to
synchronicity
those serendipities those coincidences
those uh synchronicities those
opportunities start coming to you
now what's the cool part about that
it seems like there's a shortening of
time between the thought of what you
want and the experience of what you want
between cause and effect when we create
from the fields that are from matter if
we get really good at it
then the feedback that we experience in
our life is letting us know that we're
doing something correctly and when you
start getting the phone call or the
email or the introduction to somebody
and you scratch your head and you go oh
my God I'm the creator of my life and
all of a sudden the next day your belief
in what's possible
grows dramatically so when you sit down
to do it the next time you get better at
it and all of a sudden more
synchronicities start to happen and so
the side effect of it is
uh and this is what I'm proud of in our
community is that people do the work
they don't they don't do it because they
have to do it
they do it because they don't want the
magic to end they want it they want the
synchronicities to keep happening now
as a as a young adult like you uh it's
good to learn both it's good to learn
how to function in a three-dimensional
world but when you look at the advantage
of creating what you want that becomes
the exciting part because now you you
don't have to force and control outcomes
you just have to create from the field
and then you get off from your
meditation
then your job is to stay in that state
not to return back to where is it it
hasn't happened yet you just return back
to the old person right in separation
you if you're living in the feeling of
your future every single day you would
never look for it
why would you look for it if it feels
like it's already happened that's when
the magic starts to occur so this is the
experiment called life rule number two
is focus on the destination of Bruce
Lipton one of the things that really
upset me for a long time was the fact
that I had great ideas and intentions
and I wanted to manifest them and I
thought this is how it's going to
manifest and so I had all these visions
of how things were going to unfold and
then I'd start a process and it wouldn't
unfold and then it would irritate
because like I've got to make it work I
gotta make it work uh ultimately I
started to recognize when things didn't
work it was possibly because there were
better ways to do it and I wasn't
conscious of it and so what I started to
learn over a period of time was simply
this there's an old saying there's a
means to an end and the idea well the
end is your destination
and of course the means are how you're
going to get to that destination well of
course all of us sit down and say yeah
this is what I want and then we start to
figure out well this is what I'll do to
get to those ends I'll get to this and
I'll get to this to get to the end
what I started to realize at some point
was maybe my awareness of how to get to
the end wasn't exactly accurate and it
turns out many of the times when things
didn't work and I was like so upset it
didn't work but it turned out oh there
was a better way to get there and I
didn't even know it so the universe was
really facilitating me and I wasn't
paying attention I was getting angry at
the universe because like it's not
working in a way I want it to work
and then I started to realize some point
was my God maybe the universe has a
better solution than the one I was even
thinking of myself so I really learned
over a period of time it's very critical
insight to help me get to where I am is
to focus on them on the end what is it I
really want put that Focus together and
it's very critical it's very interesting
because a lot of people have well I
would like this and it's a broad General
category and then at some point it's
like well it's not specific enough you
have to actually say what it is you want
I'll always remember I was uh looking
for a special shirt to go to a Pink
Floyd concert and and I just all of a
sudden visualize oh it'd be neat to have
a Russian shirt you know with a collar
that goes across here and a couple of
buttons down and I thought oh yeah that
would be really great that would be cool
shirt and then I stopped and I was
thinking where the heck do you get a
shirt like that I have no idea in the
world but I thought that would be pretty
good
so I figured well I still got to get
something so I drive off to a mall up
near San Francisco and I walk into the
mall and there's a first men's store
over there and I go let's start looking
I have no idea and I walked in and of
course there's this big circular rack of
sale clothes and I thought what the hell
it's only a Pink Floyd concert one night
let's see what's in there and I started
going through the wreck and lo and
behold oh my God a Russian shirt right
in the middle of everything and it was
like the shock of oh my God this is a
Russian shirt right here
the and for the unfortunate part of it
was I had the picture of a Russian shirt
I said cool I never said what the color
was or anything else I just had Russian
shirt and there was a Russian shirt
color gray no color at all why I didn't
put in the concept of color in the
universe said well just give it to him
in Gray and it was one of those things
like oh be conscious of what you're
asking for because the the more detail
you put in
the more the universe can manifest a
resolution if you leave a lot of blanks
in what you want then all of a sudden
it's like well it's random whatever
fills in the blank because you never
said what you wanted you can have an
idea what you want and that's important
but the most important part of that just
having an idea is not just have a broad
idea I want X and I go no no what
exactly do you want why
go back to the principles of Science and
the principles of science reveal
something very important that principle
of science is this Consciousness is
creating our life experiences I go well
that sounds new agey I go no this is not
new Agee this is the primary principle
of quantum physics we are creators this
is a fact in fact uh quantum physics has
that but now let me add one other fact
epigenetics says the same thing because
epigenetics says your Consciousness is
controlling your behavior and your genes
and so it's time to stop for a second
and recognize where is your
Consciousness what are you thinking
about
and the idea is start thinking all those
very positive thoughts but don't try and
tell the universe how it's going to
manifest okay you think of the picture
let the universe get you there
and that's the most important lesson
I've learned I'm not telling the
universe how I'm going to get there I'm
just saying universe is where I want to
go
and then the universe will take care of
it it's so powerful it's so wonderful
and I never believed in it for the first
40 50 years of my life but I can tell
you now the life that I'm manifesting
today is a consequence of just what I
said focus on the end don't tell the
universe the means to get there rule
number three is believe in yourself with
Marissa Pier if you think you can
and if you think you can't
you're absolutely right because you are
what you think and every athlete every
Olympic Athlete born on every celebrity
every rock star or actor that you see
must believe in themselves or people to
believe in you as an athlete as a
performer they have to believe in
themselves first they have to have a
belief that is so strong so invincible
so consistent so ever present that
others believe it do you know Muhammad
Ali said I told myself I was the
greatest before I really was the
greatest before it became true and then
it became true what a concept say I am
the greatest
and become the greatest and we'll say to
Michael Jordan gosh you're like he said
I know the more I practice
the luckier I become so what he's really
saying is I have earned my greatness and
we often look at seeing as we look at
movie stars we think well that was easy
it isn't often easy Ed Sheeran slapped
in Parks he bathed in the street he was
determined to make it he got a lot of
rejection he knew he had a phenomenal
gift a phenomenal talent and he must
share that with the world he knew that
Eminem was laughed at when he became a
rapper but he knew
that he was great he was amazing he was
gifted and if you're given that kind of
talent you certainly need to share it
Lord imagine if Eminem was a plumber if
Ed Sheeran was a builder nothing wrong
with that but we'd have never got to
share their greatness to this single
attribute people have of saying I'm good
at this I'm great at this this is my
gift this has got my name all over I was
meant to do this no one
can do this better than me
there's a great story that Celine Dion
sent a master Tate to I don't know maybe
certainly could be any recording company
and she called and said what do you
think they said we didn't like it she
said you didn't listen to it there is no
way you could hear my voice and turn me
down they were so shocked they went go
and find that cassette played it made
history they signed her but imagine she
went okay yeah I get it you don't like
my voice all right I do something else
we would never would have heard that
song My Heart Will Go On
so many people who are knocked back come
back and go no no no you don't
understand this is who I am this is what
I do I have a gift I have a voice I have
a talent
and that single attribute of knowing
they're good and telling you without
bragging
without even showing off just saying hey
this is my gift this is my skill set
this
is my area of Excellence no one can do
this better than me and imagine
if you're a flight attendant you had
that gift to say hey you're in safe
hands to be the kind of parent that
isn't intimidated by a school teacher
because you know I am the best parent I
am the best partner I'm the best at what
I do whatever you do you can be the best
at it there's someone in London called
Jane Ashley she's Paul McCartney's
girlfriend and she makes cakes only
cakes she doesn't make chicken recipes
or pies
just cakes
she charges 800 for a Cake She's written
books about cakes she has a shop just
selling cakes
and she's an expert at one thing and she
tells everyone I am the best cake maker
in the world imagine if you had that and
you could say my Nursery School my
coffee bar is the very very best because
I'm the best because I promise you if
you don't believe in you
how can someone else believe in you how
can anyone believe in you if you don't
believe in you you have the power to
access phenomenal potential to be the
best and you don't have to be famous not
everybody wants that
but you can still be the best at what
you do because I am the best hairdresser
by non and the best plumber I'm the best
contract I'm the best at having people
around to my house and making a lovely
dinner and people just love hanging out
with me because I'm so warm and friendly
and caring and entertaining imagine that
if you had such unshakable
self-belief in your gift your talent
your skill set whatever it was the other
day I was saying to someone oh I can
turn any cat they were going oh I got
this cat I said I can turn any cat I can
turn any cat with food and love because
I can I wasn't showing off it's like oh
give me this wild crazy cat I'll turn it
into a true pussycat because I can do
that because I understand animals and
they just need patience they need
dialogue they don't have to be famous to
do that but I have a friend who was
actually in the Boom Town rats he was a
rock star and when he left the Boomtown
Rats he also had that gift to turn any
animal and he created a whole company
training animals to be on stage he
actually trains the corgis that you see
in the crown he's trained so many
animals to be an advert to be on the
screen because it's his gift and he'll
say ah give me an animal I can train any
animal with love
with words I can make your pet famous if
you want me to and you really can but he
doesn't brag that's his gift so imagine
if you had that unshakable confidence in
your voice
that unshakable conviction that
Unstoppable knowing no one can do this
better than me because it's my gift it's
what I was meant to do it's what I was
put on the planet to do you might hear
people say oh I love babies I've got a
gift with babies I'm really good with
horses I'm really good with people I'm
great with old people I love listening
to their stories and it's not bragging
it's stating the truth
find out what you're good at tell
everybody
and make that a statement of Truth also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is practice
gratitude with Jack Canfield we know
that appreciation is one of the highest
emotional states you can experience and
when you cultivate appreciation and
gratitude you're able to feel Joy and
contentment no matter what you have or
don't have in your life and since the
Law of Attraction says that like
attracts like when you're grateful for
what you already have you naturally
attract more for what you can be
grateful unfortunately many people find
it requires Great diligence to cultivate
a persistent attitude of appreciation
and I think that's because we've been
culturally conditioned to focus on what
we don't have rather than appreciating
what we already have received or
achieved now to help you combat this
conditioning here are six simple tips to
make gratitude a natural part of your
daily routine so you can attract more
joy and more abundance into your life
all year long my first tip is to take
seven minutes each morning to write down
in a gratitude Journal everything you
appreciate in life and starting your day
this way primes you to be receptive and
grateful for everything your day will
bring it also helps you cultivate an air
of positivity that makes you naturally
more attractive to other positive people
and it inspires them to want to help you
achieve your goals
next make a conscious effort to
appreciate at least three people every
day and by letting people know how much
you appreciate them you increase their
own sense of appreciation and self-worth
and encourage them to pay this positive
energy forward to other people
now when most people enjoy receiving
verbal appreciation written notes are
also nice because they can be saved and
re-read now here's the third principle
or strategy you can use play the
appreciation game set a specific time
each day to consciously appreciate
everything you encounter an ideal time
to do this is on your way to or from
work
appreciate the people you pass the road
you're walking on or driving on the cars
that let you merge into a different Lane
the street signs that make it easy for
you to know where you're going the rain
that's nourishing the plants and trees
I'm in California that's a big one for
us right now and so on so look for the
good in all situations even those you
would normally view as negative and as
the saying goes every cloud has a silver
lining for example when my wife was in a
car accident a few years ago she could
have chosen to berate herself or
question or judgment instead she focused
on her gratitude for suffering only
minor injuries and for the helps you
receive from other drivers at the seat
of the accident now my fourth tip is to
carry a physical token of gratitude in
your pocket such as a heart-shaped stone
or a crystal or some other small item
that will act as a reminder so every
time you reach in your pocket it'll act
as a physical reminder to bring you back
to practice gratitude when your mind is
maybe drifted somewhere else
and as you reach into your pocket
throughout the day and you feel that
token use it as a reminder to stop
breathe and take a moment to fully
experience the emotion of gratitude
the more conscious effort you put into
seeking it out the easier it will be
able to find it and the more powerful
your experience will be
next remember to appreciate the smallest
of blessings the best way to activate
your gratitude is by acknowledging the
gifts most people take for granted if
you have food in your refrigerator if
you have clothes in your closet and a
roof over your head believe it or not
you're better off than 75 percent of the
world's population
if you eat three meals a day you are far
better off than the one billion people
on the planet who only eat once a day
do you have a phone how about a car that
allows you to travel to work or to
explore the country is your family
healthy do you have a computer and the
internet access to stay in touch with
the world
to get access to education and perform
the work for which you are paid if you
have clean water to drink not everybody
does so celebrate these simple blessings
these daily conveniences are gifts that
most people in the world do not even
enjoy
and we take for granted and finally
appreciate yourself don't forget to
appreciate your own positive qualities
and accomplishments in addition to
celebrating your big successes
acknowledge your small daily successes
as well
we all need acknowledgment but the most
important acknowledgment is that which
we give ourselves and a very powerful
way to acknowledge and appreciate
yourself is by doing the mirror exercise
for a few minutes every night talk to
yourself in the mirror and appreciate
yourself for the day's accomplishments
now practicing these six daily gratitude
habits may not feel natural at first
making me uncomfortable to focus on
appreciating what you already have but
by Faithfully practicing the daily
appreciation habits outlined in this
video you'll begin to change your
mindset and condition your subconscious
mind to bring about other things that
you can be grateful for rule number five
is understand your power with Rhonda
Byrne questions from Ramya on Facebook
what are specific steps to effortless
and fast manifestation by using The
Greatest Secret
that's a big question because it took me
a book to write
to explain it to you
um
here's the thing in The Greatest Secret
you come to understand a lot more it's
like the next big step from the secret
you understand a lot more about the mind
when you understand more about the mind
the mind doesn't trick you anymore with
its negative thoughts you understand
more about feelings and then the mind
doesn't trick you anymore with negative
feelings you also come to understand
how incredibly powerful you are that you
are the one and only Power in existence
not just a little person you're the one
and only Power in existence you come to
understand that and you also come to
understand the nature of the world that
it is not what we think it is that it's
incredible and it's fantastic but it's a
lot easier to manifest when you
understand what the world is really made
of so all of those things you'll find in
the greater secret and they go in I go
into length with all of those things and
that is why effortless manifestation
that's why manifestation becomes
effortless for you the other thing that
I want you to know you get also is the
end of suffering and Lasting happiness
that's a pretty good menu right those
those few things I mean we all just oh
you love the power so do I
so do I love the Power Audio
um we all want happiness
that's what we want like all of the
things we're wanting to manifest is we
just want them to be we just want those
things because we think we'll be happier
by the having those things and so but
imagine if you just had lasting
happiness and whatever happened in the
world didn't affect that happiness
because you can get to that point
because your true nature is happiness
and rule number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is take
small consistent actions with Lisa
Nichols I want to check in with you as
we're coming towards the end of 2022 and
what a year now today is small business
Saturday and to all my fellow business
owners I see you and I celebrate you I
know that you may be re-evaluating your
priorities right now and taking a fresh
look at all of the different areas of
your life and your business and now is a
good time to do that look at every area
of your life
look at every area of your business
I'm here today to ask you are you ready
to build a future that matches the
vision of what your 360 Abundant Life
looks like in your head
because you have a vision in your head
but are you ready to design the life
that matches that Vision are you ready
to connect the dots to what you know is
possible and what's available out there
for you are you ready to put the things
together I'm going to give it to you
straight no chaser here's the thing you
can't just dream about your ideal life I
see that happening so many times you
can't just wish for your ideal life you
can't just Google download your ideal
life you can't ask Siri or Alexa for it
you cannot do that you can't just talk
about your ideal life you have to do
some things about it for five years all
I was doing was living my dream in my
head but then I finally realized that if
I don't take action if I don't do
something soon it's just gonna stay in
my head
you have to take clear intentional
consistent action it's not thoughts that
will create your dream life though it
starts there it's the action that's
going to get you there man when I
figured that out when I figured out the
more action I'm in even if I'm in action
doing some of the wrong things I at
least realize that they're the wrong
things and I can get busy doing the
right things the more you take action
the more you build momentum the more you
build evidence that you can do this
thing even if you don't get it right
every step of the way the more you build
evidence for yourself the more confident
you'll build in yourself but all you
have to do is get into action and then
stay in action and it'll get easier and
easier and easier as you continue to
take action the people that I look at
that were moving with momentum and now
they feel stuck the common denominator
between every single person is that they
got out of action I promise you this I'm
your sister in this journey who is now
living proof and I'm not perfect but I'm
living proof that pretty soon after
enough action you may even surprise
yourself with your own extraordinary
results
your beliefs affect your world you
beliefs certainly affect your
biochemistry I've had women of 58 say
could you make me pregnant I go I know
you it's too late why did you wait 30
years but the mind will follow your
instructions and it's very important to
give yourself the right instruction of
course they're our limit you can't tell
yourself you're going to be an astronaut
and people said I want to be a
millionaire like what are you going to
do to be a millionaire you can't go
wrong with sit at home and that's the
problem with the secret attract Millions
to you what are you going to do for
these numbers I want to be have a
six-pack you do need to go to the gym I
want to have great health well stop
eating pizza and eat better food but
once you get the mind to want it it's
actually easy but when people say to me
I want to be a millionaire then we tell
them all any goal of significance
requires you to learn something new but
then they have a fear of learning and
and of course you're right then when
people will come in and go I want this
you have to look at the blocks the
number one block is the fear of
rejection if I make it I might get
rejected if I find love they might leave
if I make all that money people won't
like me anymore so you've got to smash
out of the ballpark the fear of
rejection you've got to smash out the
second belief that says it's all easy I
remember Luther Vandross saying you know
people say I'm an overnight success I
sang Jingles for KFC for 12 years
it was a long overnight so you do have
to also have that desire
I mean for me you know I speak in public
I write books always aware that
somebody's going to hate your book I
don't like it I'm like oh that's okay
they can't reject me they might reject
my book most people happen to love them
but to get anywhere in life
you have to get over the fear of
rejection
because people think they're going to
die from rejection but they really don't
what is fear is fear something that you
should fear
no
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard a
light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open isn't the signal
in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how does it keep us
alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential
Threat predator or threat at the or it
lights up the fear signals since
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the Predator will go
away so when your brain
every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're gonna
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then all I should then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed would succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a different uh the
same example with just a little
different story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great to take a
picture of me with it so I put on social
media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stained stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking I used to struggle a lot
with manifesting just the idea of it I
would watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it uh
whether it's manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
code of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
and it's too blurry you're still looking
at my face you're looking at my car
you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often why that's your reticular
activating system basically saying I
want to pay attention to those things so
that car was still around right I mean I
I got this car we've got a Porsche and
now I see Porsches more often those
Porsches still existed they were they
were already there I just didn't notice
them before and now I notice them
because I have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with and as soon as I
came up with an idea I was like oh you
can't do that or I had to have the
perfect Plan before I would ever take
any kind of action on it and you know
just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe that great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
let's say you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust it it's to write it and then
go do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh seventy thousand people
you know I am I am the author of a
best-selling book uh I am like whatever
your goal is and what I think the point
of that is is yes one to see yourself
accomplishing big things uh two to not
have a be so far away that it lets you
off the hook for taking action but I
think most importantly is for you to
feel what it feels like to be that and
the more you feel like it feels like to
be that the more it actually becomes
true if your goal is to speak on stage
in front of five thousand people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and just 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a speaker
in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy David but look
I've got I've got a belly or I've got a
you know whatever I'm I'm I am healthy I
am healthy and and visualizing yourself
being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that I judged and
that I didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too you
will never find working a pleasure if
you hate your job or you can't stand
your boss what a terrible affirmation
that is it will be impossible for you to
ever attract a great job with that
belief system if you want to enjoy your
time at work then you must change your
thinking I'm a great believer in
blessing with love every person place
and thing at the workplace begin with
your current job affirm that this job is
merely a stepping stone to far greater
positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking perhaps
you learned your attitude towards work
from your parents no matter you can
change your thinking now
so bless with love your boss your
co-workers the location the building the
stairs or elevators the rooms the
furniture and each and every customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
I have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work if you are an owner a manager or
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful we all want
to be appreciated acknowledged and
encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
Consciousness will open the pathway for
you don't have faith in fear when you
hear of negative Trends in business or
in the economy immediately affirm that
may be true for some but it is not true
for me I always Prosper no matter where
I am or what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make the relationships at work be
smoother
in fact for many people this is a really
big issue in their lives I am deeply
aware that whatever I give out comes
back to me multiplied and this is true
everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
Divine Harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have Solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the Divine Right action solution to any
Discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any Discord or
confusion as it comes up it's important
to release all blame and turn within to
seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your Consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
Divine Harmony Reigns Supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to Divine principles
then Divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love
expressing gratitude for what you do
have enables it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers your Consciousness
puts you where you are now your changing
Consciousness can lift you to a better
position you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one before you go to work every day do
this simple exercise just sit
comfortably and concentrate on your
breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two write or type this affirmation and
put it where you can see it at work my
job is a peaceful Haven I bless my job
with love I put love in every corner and
my job lovingly responds with warmth and
comfort I am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
I only give out that which I wish to
receive my love and acceptance of others
is mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a Divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work no matter where I
am there is only infinite good Infinite
Wisdom infinite Harmony and love your
personality literally ad is made up of
how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called the memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened or it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life and less of the
victim of your life see the only
criteria you have to have when you set a
goal is do you want
do you want it doesn't matter how you're
going to do it it doesn't matter where
the money's coming from
I want shared a cute story with the
maharashi when he was taking
Transcendental Meditation or decided it
was going to take into the world one of
his Coast Associates said where's the
money going to come from he said
wherever it is right now I always
thought it was such a beautiful answer
because the truth everything you need
everything you want is already here
nothing is created or destroyed I didn't
dream this up it's the way it is all
science all theology tell us that the
way to get the moon was already here
always here when President John Kennedy
asked Dr Warner Von Braun who's
considered the the father of the space
travel what it would take to build a
rocket that would carry a man to the
moon and bring him back safely to her
Von Braun answered I mean five words the
will to do it
the will to do it will is a mental
faculty that gives us the ability to
concentrate you got to concentrate on
what you want that's all you can
concentrate on and that will keep you on
the frequency that you have to be on to
attract everything that you need to get
there
this is so important
to say I believe decision where it all
starts
it's where it all started for Napoleon
Hill
it all started when Carnegie asked him
are you prepared to dedicate the rest of
your life to an idea for which you'll
probably receive no material
compensation for at least 20 years how
would you answer that
you see he didn't know how to do that
he didn't even believe he could
you know what I found when you set a
goal you don't have to believe it
if you keep repeating it you'll come to
believe it if you tell yourself a lie
often enough you'll believe it
way back in 1900 William James from
Harvard he said believe in your belief
will create the fact
so true so true and so misunderstood
so what do you want
compare your dream
to Napoleon Hill's idea
just compare it for a moment
your idea is probably small by
comparison
but if you don't know how to do it if
you don't know where the money's coming
from if you don't know where the help is
going to come from
you'll probably seem large
when I took my pen and I sat down and I
wrote I would build a company that
operated all over the world
I had no idea how I was going to do it I
certainly didn't have the finances to it
I didn't have the help I didn't even
have an assistant I was just me in my
Den riding on a pad
do you know something
today I own a company
along with Sandy Gallagher who is my
business partner and we operate all over
the world
these aren't accidents
I'm just an ordinary guy
that's doing what the public would
consider something extraordinary but
it's not extraordinary to me and it's
not going to be to you when you start to
understand these principles and
incorporate them into your life I
mentioned we want to build schools in
Africa for kids that have never seen a
school and so we're building them
there's many things we want to do we do
them all I never wonder if I can do
something
I just ask myself do I want to
way I think God meant us to live
I believe we're doing God's work
somebody said what the God's word god
well if God's a Creator then God's work
would be creation we've been given the
mental faculties to create
we've been created in God's image
somewhere along the line way back when
somebody got that mixed up
[Music]
they thought when they said you're
creating God's image that God was
created in their image so they're
looking for a man on a cloud there is no
man on a cloud but I'm going to tell you
something
you got some phenomenal stuff locked up
inside of you you bring it to the
surface you can live anything you want
great way to live
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome here's a
manifestation technique to listen to
every day it's right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I think the Law
of Attraction and manifesting are the
same thing so Law of Attraction for
everybody who has not read the secret is
simply your thoughts become things and
it's true we've talked all about how
when you have a negative self-talk it
tends to draw